[Musique]
c'est le gars c'est le gars ont raconté
des chaussures qui sera comme c'est
quand même ces cas il ya quand même
vachement de gollum
et battu voir si je sais qu'ils doivent
bientôt se marier avec fatou j'espère
que tu as tout nous regarde pas des
voitures
des chauffards mais tekken et qu'elle
regarde cadre sympa ça va franchement on
sait qu'elles
savent havre et c'est quand même un
goitre
tu vois tu prépares qui pour quoi
attendez attendez jamais valérie bénaïm
valérie valérie bénaïm valérie bénaïm
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie de la déconne comme avant
c'est vrai
mais derrière
pendant l'émission
gilles on pourra pas de garder
encore
imaginer que cet été entre indiens non
c'est une arnaque
j'ai mal à ma france non mais il en fait
on sait que ça va être chaud gars
tout en fait tu vois c'est pas à
attendait un an géraldine maillet
jardinage géraldine manille
mais c'est dingue quand je vous vois en
vrai la différence
sinon je
dirais monter le mieux c'est le mieux
lotis
[Applaudissements]
côté nagui tu peux
la tête et les aides c'est que tu es
beaucoup alors n'a pas beaucoup mieux
mais des mets tes pas mal et je savais
déjà c'est vrai que c'est mieux ça fait
quand même
et c'est vrai apparemment non mais là
certes été mieux tu avais de losail
après on habite là c'est après la
revente du cap et
on aa bat daniel moreau à 20 on a
vraiment un an avant alors maintenant
est d'aller le mot après regardez
il ya pas grand chose s'est passé ici
le mot c'est que c'est passé à gala
alors que nous venons vais dire regardez
qu'est la wii
alors c'est
claire chazal
elle aura sera polluants mais
on a mis dix piges me sens pas de faire
de commentaire
80 ans
par contre alors on a alors le meilleur
pour moi c'est castaldi rien
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
aïe aïe aïe
la poitrine a pas
mais c'est arrivé à pékin et
madrid
enfin mais enfin on a on a aussi
regardé moi regardez regardez
toujours aussi avenant
mais j'ai surtout pensé à tout et moi
c'est sûr
ah ouais on dirait vraiment on dirait
que tu vas avoir un accent genre qui est
sérieux
c'est très pénible en peluche un accent
comme à 10 et enfin guillaume genton que
ça regardez regardez
donc j'attends mon fric
[Applaudissements]
pour les animaux c'était un gars qui est
animateur c'est
vraiment la star des stars oui c'est
vrai qu'il ressemble aux gars voilà
montrez moi je connais pas vraiment plus
de vrai je connais pour de vrai je
connais pas c'est un vrai gars et un
frigo
le jeu parce que
c'est vrai que moi là bas mais on dirait
vraiment votre arme non mais sans
déconner on dirait la bce c'est fou
comme il me ressemble prenez vous le
connaissiez ou pas vous aviez jamais vu
ne dit jamais vu guy lux urgent fait
qu'il est mort mais non mais au calme
toi ça a été mon premier pour deux mais
il est décédé oui bah il perd longtemps
et je l'adoré
c'est lui qui a inventé un terme il
était très grand et tout le schmilblic
que j'allais jallet 36 rue des alouettes
mois pour le voir guy
tu rencontres parfois que tu es dans une
émission
[Rires]
aussi je suis allé dans des adresses sur
neuf ou deluxe aussi mais non mais tu
veux dire moi aussi je suis allée 36 rue
des acacias voir mon père
l'info média bulletin d'infos médias la
sfp les anciens succès pc aux buttes
chaumont ouais bah tu vois pas y aller
la
prise unique
mais aussi bon
je te le dis tu jettes tout le monde non
mais franchement vous êtes très mal
entouré non ça va c'est vrai la preuve
qu
une minute une info tu as pris quoi toi
acquis baghadi al jardine n'ont pour
l'instant je suis pas j'ai pas commencé
[Rires]
le probléme ans il ya maire
d'armentières noyau il manque bien là
c'est lui
c'est pas mal ça va mal raison il
ressemble de ouf un prof j'avais au
lycée de physique-chimie qu'était cette
terre le saumon tiennent là dessus là il
est vener l'âge vient de lui refuser un
prime
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas je soutiens et green on the
way fait réglé alors que ce n'est pas le
cas de bernard qu'est loin qui est tout
sauf aigris qui laisse penser que dans
20 ans vous frappez pmp avec nos vieux
tout vieux réunit alors on va déjà il
faut que vous soyez tous
avaient survécu aux cobras
mais john lennon mais oui oui quoi oui
oui j'y pense oui bah oui je pense oui
j'y pense 80 cas mais franchement c'est
par vingt projets que j'en sais tu dois
[Rires]